okay so if you're keeping score a lot at
home volume type one just around the
x-axis normal one point number two
around the y-axis and here's gonna be
three and four so what if you want to
take and you'll see why in a second what
you want to take the wrong area and
rotate that okay so here instead of the
area underneath the axis and just so we
don't get confused what if I take the
area above think with me secretly I'm
still doing the same kind of rotation
what will happen as I rotate that shape
around well think about it like this I'm
going to I'm going to draw it the same
way I did the other ones right what kind
of um circles are gonna be on the ends
like from the beginning and stop well
let's have a look at this one quizzes
this is the radius that I'm rotating
yeah so what kind of circle will I get
when I rotate it in size this is three
that's three up there it's gonna be a
second it's gonna go all the way down to
negative three okay
and that's solid right now what about
the other boundary well up here I have a
radius of now stop for a second
up here it's actually zero right like
it's at a point yes but importantly it's
at a point that it's up here right so
whenever I take this around you know its
opposite is gonna end up at minus three
as well right it's gonna have this kind
of shape hmm you join that up because
you've got all of these lines over here
right and they're all gonna retain
they're gonna end up down the bottom
right but that's a cylinder and you know
we got the cylinder not by retaining
this kind of line but right by rotating
in the horizontal right so what's the
difference between this and a cylinder
yeah it's been I've cut out the middle
right the shape in the middle is the
current right yeah it's empty okay
this part here that I'm rotating I'm
rotating empty space yes
so this here if you like this is where
your extra colors in your shading I'm
now looking inside this is kind of like
a um a weird Cup I guess you'd hold it
and if you look inside it's it's a
common shape okay so how I work out I
would think okay this big shape on the
outside is a cylinder I know how to work
out some of those and this shape in here
the cone or if it wasn't a kind if it
was some other kind of shape like a
curved shape whatever that volume is I'm
going to subtract it okay so I'm gonna
do it one step is fine let's work out
the volume of this cylinder okay the
volume of any cylinder is PI R squared H
right okay so just have a look what are
the radius and height of this cylinder
with Rhea sideways right radius is three
okay which would also work okay and then
the height here is well by coincidence
I've just made a kind of square so you
might face it this is 27 oh yeah sorry
no wait longer you mean why don't I go
cuz it seeks across yeah that's right
okay now the next volume I'm gonna write
it as I could call it volume in the cone
okay but as you can imagine like
depending on what I make this function
ia might be any kind of weed wonderful
shape right so I'm gonna call it the
internal volume because it's the Boyne
that's inside and that helps me that's a
tag for me to say I'm gonna subtract
this that's what I'm gonna do with it
now the volume of any kind of shape
right is a baby y squared DX right so
now this part here the area aren't
subtractive that's that's the same as
integral type one right
into volume type one yeah it's just the
cone okay so in this case that's where i
couldäôt you know pi you're going from
nought to three and it's x squared yes
we can carry on from there pi x cubed on
three so what we got nine pi - year yeah
so having set up these two I could say
therefore the actual volume is one - and
then you can slap on units okay yeah
let's just pause for a moment before we
go on to the UM the doing around the y
axis but the same idea the subtraction
idea do we have to go separately do we
have to work out two volumes and then
take the difference because you may
remember from when we were doing areas
that we're doing areas if I asked you to
work out say this area right if if you
had the parabola y equals x squared okay
and then y equals x y what did you work
out the difference okay you could work
out two integrals right but we very
quickly saw you might as well just whack
them into one integral right I mean in
this case it would be integral from I
mean where they intersect that's one one
right so you go from nought to one
what's on which area is on top just X
right because that's the straight one so
X then you used to track the one on the
bottom and then you're going with
respect and that's the problems gives
you the right answer you can do okay now
here's the question can I do the same
trick with volumes okay now I want you
to think about this before you commit to
an answer because I want you all to
think about when your own be convinced
and not be like it was by someone else
including me can we simply like I've got
one function up here and another
function here instead of going this long
way work out a whole
they both have pies at the front right
you're both going to be able in the same
domain can I simply subtract the volumes
the functions first and then take a ball
okay so let's test it out remember what
I said all right okay let people make up
annoyance okay so this just consider
okay a little try and work out a volume
right so all the ones have a PI out the
front I already know what my boundaries
are there's still zero to three okay now
I'm going to try and do this trick here
which is you've got these functions
right and you take the difference okay
well the top function is 3 and the lower
function is x top function lower
function now this point you know this is
PI R squared right so this ought to be
square thank you going DX now I for my
definite integral okay let's give it a
whirl
actually I should probably expand this
you could do chain rule I'm gonna
explain it anyway a bit lazy this is 9
minus 6x plus x squared with respect to
X so just keep it up there further okay
because wait till like it's the last
line okay what's my integral 9x minus 3x
squared plus X cubed 3 from north to 3
oh my gotta get to you oh we're gonna
get pie outside all that's a 27 that's
27 right and that's a third yeah sorry
20:27 look that's 9 right all right I'm
thinking you're integrating why don't I
putting one in anyway um and then
because they're all X terms there's a
zero yeah - yeah how'd I miss something
Oh No okay so this looks promising
doesn't it it's pretty good yeah mmm
who's convinced
happy put your hand up if you're
convinced if you think this is fun this
is fine
I'll let you stare up for as long as you
like all of you all of you see by the
way by the way please don't missus this
is a critically important moment to have
okay because I want you to make up your
own mind
okay the fact that I'm having this whole
conversation with you or to signal is
something going on but but what is going
on if there is something like that why
okay so I want you to come to your own
conclusion I don't want you to get into
an answer at the end right yes we can do
this
no we can't right just because I tell
you right because when you going to be
daddy to be like now what do you say why
is it like I trusted him but now I can't
remember it seriously so many people
learn Matt's on trust they do cuz like I
didn't get it teacher said so textbook
says so just use it okay I want you to
convince as to why it works or doesn't
work then why why not okay we're gonna
leave that there for a second to draw
something else
I mean if it's simple look it didn't
take me a lot of work to do that do that
and then that's actually easy to and
chain rule huh
you know Ariel creeping if you forget to
divine or whatever if if the power were
higher as the power increased like if
that's three already by three it's too
much work to turn so then I'll go tangle
yeah